[Music]
hi
i'm hedley wickham and today i'm excited
to talk to you about a topic that's near
and dear to my heart
code maintenance this certainly isn't
one of the sexiest topics
but as your career in programming
advances it becomes increasingly
important
and today i wanted to talk about code
maintenance through the lens of home
maintenance
because in many ways i think the tidy
verse is a little bit like a hardware
store
we don't build the house for you we
don't do the data analysis for you
but we provide you the tools to do it
and like a good hardware store we also
help you pick the right tools
and give you some education about how to
use them effectively
now unlike most hardware stores we also
develop we also build many of the tools
that we sell
so we're also listening to hear what
your problems are with the tools to
learn how we can make them better
i've also been thinking about code
maintenance and home maintenance
a little bit more than usual lately
because of a very frustrating experience
that i had recently
if you don't own your own home you might
kind of think of houses as things that
just like exist
but in reality they generate the steady
stream of small maintenance
tasks and one that i needed to tackle
recently was a couple of exterior lights
stopped working
and so i thought you know this seems
like a pretty simple task this should be
something i can tackle by myself
and take maybe an hour or two on a trip
to home depot
four hours and three trips to home depot
later i gave up
frustrated and extremely angry and so
the first thing
i want to talk about today is how do you
deal with that frustration that comes up
while doing maintenance
like how do you deal with all those
negative emotions that this thing that
should just work
doesn't and when i'm taking a home
maintenance task like this
and it's going wrong i often start
telling myself these pretty negative
stories
like this is a really simple task and
if i can't perform it then i must be an
idiot
or you know i'm looking at the
documentation in the box it describes
how to install these lights
looking at what's on the outside of my
house and they look
nothing alike like the documentation is
utterly useless like it must have been
an idiot
who wrote this or at the end of those
four hours
you know i'm just i just tell myself
that was a total waste of time
you never get those four hours back
and maybe you are much better at home
maintenance than i am
you almost certainly are but you might
have experienced some of these thoughts
when dealing with code maintenance with
dealing with the
the fact that your code hasn't your code
that worked fine a couple of years ago
hasn't changed but it breaks today and
now you've got to do all of this extra
work to get it working again
and i think a really useful technique to
deal with these emotions with these
thoughts
is to have some kind of rational canned
responses you can tell yourself
so for me it's telling myself well you
know actually i don't do that much home
maintenance it's kind of unreasonable to
expect that i'd be an expert at it right
away
or you know it's it's un like there's no
way
the documentation could explain what
every single light looks like
on every single person's house in the
world so i can't expect the
documentation is going to apply
exactly to my situation but it should
contain some
some hints so i can read it and take
away some important messages
and then sure i didn't succeed in the
goal but
it's not a waste of time at least i've
learned in the future i need to budget
more time
and now i know where all the various
pits and pieces are at home depot so
i've saved some time for the future as
well
now this technique comes from cognitive
behavioral therapy it's a way of
responding to these automatic thoughts
with kind of balanced alternatives and
you can apply it yourself in lots of
situations the main thing
is to when you come up with these
balance alternatives it's very very
difficult to do that in the moment
you want to sit down when you're in a
good place and think about
some of these negative thoughts that
come up and how you can argue against
them
i learned about this technique a few
years ago when i read this read this
book called
feeling good by david b d burns this the
whole
the whole idea of cognitive behavioral
therapy i think is really
powerful because it gives you this
toolkit for
understanding how your thoughts and
emotions are connected together
and how by changing your thoughts
sometimes you can succeed in
changing your emotions
now that's obviously a very generous
technique for dealing with frustration
however it arises in your health in your
life
but i think it's also worth recognizing
like where does frustration
come from because i think at the heart
of pretty much every frustration
is this conflict between what you want
to be true
and some unyielding reality
and i think it's easy to think it's easy
to think like when you write
code that you're creating this this
monolith that will last a thousand years
that
you wrote some code two years ago you
can tell your code hasn't changed
why doesn't it work today
and the reason is you know while your
code might may not have changed
the world has changed around it and
instead of thinking about code as this
kind of monolith i think it's better to
think about
code more like a smoke alarm it's
something that needs regular maintenance
you have to change the batteries once a
year and replace the whole thing
every 10 years now let's start to get
into some more of the details of dealing
with change in code
and this is a place where the metaphor
of the hardware store
starts to break down a little because
once you've purchased something from the
hardware store it changes it stays the
same
but when you use code from a package
that code might work differently
when you update the package this is a on
the on the
on the whole this is normally a good
thing this is like the package developer
can come into your house
replace all of those expensive
inefficient incandescent bulbs
with new led bulbs that are much more
efficient
you get new features you get bug fixes
you get performance improvements
but any updates to a package also comes
with a risk that it might break your
code
and i want to talk a little in a little
bit more detail about how we think about
that particularly in the tidy verse
these ideas apply in general but i'm
going to talk about the kind of
framework that we are using currently in
the tidy list
and i want to talk a little bit about
the kind of set of promises the tidy
verse
money back guarantee if you will that
that we want to provide to you so that
you can better understand
what is likely to break your code and
what's likely not to break your code
and to do that we first have to talk a
bit about the tidy verse life cycle
so you might have seen this before
because the documentation
of certain functions contains these
badges
like life cycle deprecated or life cycle
superseded
so the full tidy vest life cycle is
relatively complicated
but today i wanted to talk about the
four most important components
experimental deprecated stable
and superseded and you can kind of
roughly divide these
in half by whether their functions in
these various stages are kind of
out of warranty or in warranty
i'll talk about what that means
precisely shortly
but roughly you know if a function is
out of warranty it might change at any
point
if it's in warranty we have some pretty
strict strip we make some pretty strict
promises about how it will change
so out of warranty we've got
experimental on the one hand
these are new functions new features we
don't know exactly
how they should work but we want to get
them out of the world so that you can
try them out and give us feedback
this is the type of code that you need
to have a pretty close relationship with
you need to be working with it a lot
because it's going to it's going to
change based on your feedback
now most functions are on the stable
life cycle
that means the developer is basically
happy with them and has no major plans
to change in the future
there's two ways that a function kind of
it can exit
that stable life cycle stage it can
become deprecated
which means basically that it's a bad
idea you should stop using it
or it can become superseded we know that
there's a better alternative but the
the old the odd function's not going
away
so the first thing we're going to
guarantee the first promise we're going
to make you
is if we're going to try and avoid as
much as possible to make breaking
changes in any stable functions
so breaking change is a change that we
expect
we predict will break the vast majority
of correctly written code
that uses it so what are some examples
of breaking changes
well firstly if you remove a function
obviously any code that uses that
function is going to break
or if you remove an argument to a
function any code that uses the argument
or if you decrease the set of allowed
inputs to an argument
that's also going to break some code so
in general
making a function the scope of a
function kind of smaller
is going to be a breaking change because
code that works
today will not work after this change
happens
now as well as the input to a function
there's also the output changing the
type
of an output type of type of the output
of a function is also a breaking change
if a function previously returned a
numeric vector and now it returns a data
frame it's likely to break
so what are non-breaking changes well of
course we can change the output because
we have to be able to fix bugs
and this means that technically
something that's a non-breaking change
can still actually break your code if
you've accidentally depended on a bug
so this is a really important topic that
i'm going to come back to later
when we talk about off-label usage of
functions
otherwise non-breaking changes are
generally increasing the scope of things
so
increasing the possible set of allowed
inputs adding new arguments or adding
new functions so anything that grows
the interface of a function or a package
is going to be a non-breaking change
now sometimes we will have to make a
breaking change
to a function that is stable but we're
never going to do that
suddenly we're going to do it through a
gradual process of deprecation
we're going to give you a chance to find
out that something is changing
and respond to that change before we
take it away for good
so what does that look like well let's
take a function from the table package
called data underscore frame
now we probably i created this function
when we just started working working
with the idea of tibbles
and because tibbles are kind of like a
modern reimagining of a data frame
i thought well let's give it a modern
name by
taking the dot and replacing with an
underscore
now pretty soon afterwards i realized
that was a kind of
cutesy and b misleading because this
function doesn't return a data frame
it returns a tipple so we decided to
deprecate that function
so what happens if you call that
function today well you're going to get
a warning that tells you it's deprecated
and it tells you when it was deprecated
so temple 1.1 was actually released in
2016 about four years ago
so deprecated functions don't go away
immediately
they're going to hang around for a while
so that you can find out about the
change
generally more the more important or the
more widely used the function was
the longer that deprecation message will
hang around
next you're going to find out what you
should use instead so here you can use a
tibble function instead it does exactly
what it says on the
on the tin it creates a table for you
now what happens if you're looking at
some old code
that has hundreds of data underscore
frame calls in it
it would be super annoying if every
single one of those generated a message
so we're only going to show you this
warning every eight hours
but it's also important for you to fix
these deprecated functions
so we're going to help you find out
where they were by giving you those
this advice to call this life cycle's
last warnings function
there's one important thing that you do
not see here and that's an
error so a deprecated function does not
generate an
error it still works it still does
exactly the same thing it used to do
but it is going to go away in the future
and the warning message is going to
suggest going to encourage you to update
so if you do call that last warnings
function you'll get that same message
again
and you'll also get a back trace and a
back trace is just the sequence of
function calls that eventually led
to that deprecated function in this
made-up example we've got a function
f that cause g that goes h equals i that
finally calls data underscore frame
and this is quite important because it
allows you to narrow in exactly where
that warning is coming from
as quickly as possible we really do not
want deprecated functions to be
that one smoke alarm in your house that
needs its batteries changed
and it feels like the beep is like
perfectly calibrated it's fast enough it
happens frequently enough that it like
drives you to the point of insanity
but not frequently enough that you can
ever figure out which of the four smoke
alarms it's actually coming from
now the life cycle stages i've talked
about them mostly in the context of
functions they also
apply to packages in slightly different
ways and they also apply
to arguments of functions and even
specific values
of arguments of functions and so for
example in the the nest function and
taria 1.0
we wanted to update it to match emerging
consensus
of interface function interface across
the tidy verse
so we deprecated one argument and we
deprecated another way of using
dot dots
so deprecated functions are functions
that are kind of moving
deprecated functions features arguments
are things that are moving out of
warranty
what about things that we just kind of
regret
a little they're not wrong but maybe
there's a better alternative available
now
that's the idea of the superseded life
cycle stage
which i'm going to talk about with a
little example because
a few years ago it sort of felt like
there was this disturbance
in the tidal verse force that a lot of
people were having problems remembering
like which of spread and gather was
which and how do you actually use them
like every time you go to use them you
have to look up the documentation or do
some time googling
and this this just wasn't happening to
the community this was also happening to
me
like i forgot how to use these functions
which seemed like a really good sign it
was time to put some work into them
and so last year we spent a bunch of
time talking to the community
looking at other approaches taken by
packages like a data table
and we came up with two new functions
pivot longer which makes your data
longer
and pivot wider which makes your data
wider
and overall it seems like that that
those new functions have been successful
people have found them or at least
people in this cherry pick sequence of
tweets have found them much easier to
use
and remember
but just because pivot longer and pivot
wider exist
and are great and easy to remember it
doesn't mean that spread and gather are
wrong or bad
they still do what they said they still
do what they say in the turn they still
do
they still work the same way that they
always have and by any means they're
you know some of the most successful
functions i've ever written probably
used by hundreds of thousands of people
so spread and gather are never going to
go away but we want to make it
clear that newer
approaches are available and that's the
idea of this superseded life cycle badge
which basically says
this function the development is now
complete it's never going to get any new
features
and it will only receive the sorts of
critical bug fixes that will keep that
function alive and useful
and to me the way that i think about
superseded functions is kind of like the
idea of building codes
so building code is a set of best
practices that you need to apply
when you are building a new home today
and obviously over time those standards
evolve
so what happens if you have a 50 year
old home or 100 year old home do you
have to go and
update your house to meet all of today's
standards
that would be crazy so the idea of
building standards is
they are important when you are building
a new house or whenever you touch
something in your existing house
so if you're renovating your kitchen and
discovery the wiring is no longer up to
code
you're going to have to replace that but
you don't have to rip out all of the
walls all of the wires in your house
elsewhere in your house
and the same applies to superseded
functions
really good idea to use them in new
projects if you are touching old
projects if you're renovating old
projects update superseded functions
when you need them
but don't otherwise worry about it's
totally fine for the old and the new to
coexist
seamlessly the other place it's
worthwhile updating is if you're
teaching
really important when you're teaching to
be teaching the latest best practices as
much as possible
you might wonder well when do these when
are these superseded functions going to
go away
and you know i don't want to make any
promises like i can't commit to
who knows what our priorities are going
to be in five years or 10 years and what
our resources will be
but i think you can get some sense of
how we care about superseded functions
by looking at some superseded packages
like
for example the reshape package which i
wrote in 2005
and was superseded in 2010 by reshape 2.
so because people are still using it
because packages are still using it
you know we've kept reshape still
working it's not getting any new
features
so it's not a lot of work we're going to
keep that alive on crayon as long as
possible
similarly same story for player and
reshape 2
both created a long time ago they've
been superseded
we're going to keep those functions
those packages are live and on cran for
you know the foreseeable future
now so far i've talked about these life
cycle stages
which we as the creators of the
functions have control over
there's an important thing that you have
control over which is how you
use functions and i want to talk a
little bit about the kind of off-label
usage of functions
because a medication off-label usage is
basically prescribing a medicine for
something that's not formally approved
approved for this is not
uh illegal it's not wrong it's useful in
lots of cases because there's lots of
knowledge about medication that hasn't
been formally approved yet
but it is a little riskier than using
something for its intended purpose
and particularly for functions it
exposes you to i think to a greater risk
of breakage
so what exactly do i mean by off label
usage
let's take a little example i have got a
factor
and i want to extract the underlying
numeric levels of the factor
now one way to do this is to use the c
function
because the c function doesn't know how
to handle factors and so it just drops
all the levels
but i would say that this is off label
usage because the job of the c
function is to concatenate vectors
concatenate or combine vectors together
and here we've only got one vector so
you
or someone else you in the future or
someone else looking at this code might
scratch your head a little bit and think
well
what does it mean to combine one vector
here you're really relying on kind of a
side effect an unintended side effect of
the c
function which because it doesn't know
about factors drops those levels
you're going to be much better off
explicitly declaring that you want to
get the integer
underlying integer levels by using
something like as dot integer
or maybe you've got a data frame and you
want to find all the rows in this data
frame
where x equals 1 and you do that using
subsetting in r and because r
has this you know fantastic rule that
missing values don't go silently missing
you're going to get a missing row on the
output which a lot of the times is not
what you want
and so you might think well i'll just
use which to get rid of this
now this certainly isn't such an
egregious off-label usage as the last
example
but the primary purpose of which is to
find the location
of true values and a logical vector so
this
no it's hard to know what else which
would do with missing values
but you're not really fully
communicating what you're trying to do
here what you're trying to do is remove
missing values
and so in this case i think you're
better off switching to a function like
d
plus filter or base subset explicitly
designed for subsetting rows of a data
frame
which knows that you don't want to get
those n a rows back
and the reason you want to avoid this
off label usage is because the original
author has no way to anticipate
what you're doing and so when they make
changes to the function
it's much more likely to negatively
affect these off-label usages
than the documented usage
so and another way of saying that is off
label usage is going to void your
warranty
all bits are off when you start using a
function in a way that the author did
not envisage
so how do you avoid it well
the first thing you need to recognize is
that recognizing understanding off-label
usage and what the intended purpose of a
function is
is a skill it's not something that
you're born knowing
it's something you're going to develop
over the course of your career in art
and in particular when you start out
learning r
your primary goal is to solve the
problem in front of you and get the
result that you need
and that is 100 okay
but as you get better it's really good
practice to think are you using
functions not just because
they do what you want but because they
do what they say
and the easiest way to discover that is
to read the documentation
if you are using a function for a
purpose that is not mentioned
anywhere in its documentation you are
getting a little you're likely to be in
the danger zone
but i think the best technique for
learning more about the intended usage
of our functions is to do code review
so this is going to help you when you
get your code reviewed by someone else
because they're going to look at that
they're going to look at you
concatenating a single factor and
they're going to ask you like
what are you doing here because the
chances are they don't know all the same
quirks of the functions that you do
they'll know the intended purpose of a
function but they're less likely to know
some side effect that you're relying on
but code review also helps you when
you're reading other people's code
because you've got to look at that code
and you're going to think about it
you're going to say well
like what is this doing and maybe you'll
read a little bit of documentation
you'll learn some new functions
and that that process of reflecting on
other people's code
is really going to help you understand
and improve
your ability to write good code
personally
one of the biggest improvements to my
coding style i think happened when i
started
grading code when i started teaching
data analysis at rice university
that process of having to read other
people's code
and think about like why was this hard
to understand
really made it my own code much more
elegant and clearer
now while off-label usage of a function
will void your warranty
we as maintainer of the packages still
want to avoid unforeseen consequences
as much as possible and i think there's
a really
interesting unforeseen consequence of
this transition
from incandescent light bulbs to led
light bulbs
and that is a few years a few years back
cities started converting the traffic
lights from incandescent led because it
saved
a bunch of time and they don't need to
be replaced as frequently and they used
much much less power
but unfortunately the first winter after
this happened
they discovered a problem that snow was
accumulating in the traffic lights and
blocking them so people couldn't see
them
and this was because the one of the
reasons that led bulbs or so
one of the reasons that incandescent
bulbs were so inefficient
was that they also produced a bunch of
heat
and so um now previously they would have
melted all the
melt of the snow and now with these new
led bulbs they
didn't snow accumulated and there were a
bunch of car crashes
so in the tiny verse we want to avoid
that as much as possible by
trying for particularly when we make big
changes to making sure that there aren't
common off-label usages that we need to
support
and i want to talk about this and the
context of a recent change to magruder
a set of big changes that improve back
traces so when you get an error message
it's much easier to see where in the
pipeline it actually happened
there's much less overhead so it's
faster
and it is much closer to the upcoming
base pipe so i think these are three
really big and important improvements
but to get them we had to fundamentally
re-engineer how the pipe worked
and our analysis suggested that it
should be fine
for you know any correct usage of the
pipe or any way that we use the pipe
um but we wanted to make sure it's not
going to
there weren't a bunch of uses that we
hadn't imagined that we that we still
needed to support
so we did three things and you can learn
from those three things
so the first thing we always do is we
always run our command
check on all of the packages that use
our package on cran
now code and cran packages is not
exactly the same as data analysis code
but it is a very large body of our code
that is very easy for us to rerun
so this is a great first pass to pick if
there's any major problems with a new
version of our package
and this is also you know if you can go
to the effort of putting a package on
cran
this also gets you some extra protection
before any package and the tidy verse
changes
all of your tests will be rerun and
we'll tell you if we've broken something
we also tweeted about it we tweet about
pretty much everything we do following
us on twitter
is a great way to keep up with the
latest and greatest changes in the tidy
verse
and for but for changes of this
magnitude we also blog about it
and so in this case leonel wrote a blog
post saying hey there's a big new
version of
magritta coming along please try it out
and let us know
what you think does it does it break
anything in your code
and in the process of coming up with a
slide i realized if you don't use
twitter and you don't use blogs how are
you supposed to
keep up with these things so we're going
to add a mailing list so you can easily
sign up for
updates over email and then in the not
too distant future
now when we did this for magruder we
actually uncovered a bunch of smaller
and not so small things
so we either fixed mcgregor to make this
work or if we couldn't do that
at least make it give an informative
error message
but there were still a few things where
the trade-off
between the amount of time it would take
to fix them versus the frequency of the
usage
in the community and at the end of the
day we have to kind of make this balance
that we are going to pick
these large positive improvements for
the vast majority of people
is an okay trade-off for a few new
problems for a very small amount of
people
now even after learning about the
tidiverse life cycle
and the various promises that we make to
you you might still feel nervous
that for particularly critical projects
you might be worried that an otherwise
innocuous package update
might break your code and so you have a
fallback which is to opt out
of the hurley burley of package updates
now this
is generally not a good idea because
you're not just
opting out of uh changes that might
break your code
you're also opting out of bug fixes and
improvements and new features
but for some types of code particularly
code that is run
unintended unattended like code and
production
it can be a good idea to use one of
these techniques
so that your code is 100 isolated and
protected from changes to other packages
so the first thing you can do is use the
rn package basically what this is going
to do is it's going to isolate each
project you work on
give it its own library of our packages
so
it doesn't matter what you install
elsewhere this pack this
project will always use the same set of
packages
it also comes with a pair of functions
that let you save those package versions
to disk
and then restore them elsewhere so you
can run your code on another computer
and it'll hopefully give you exactly the
same results because you've installed
exactly the same versions of packages
now because rn works by giving you a
custom library of packages and isolated
library packages
it works with any packages it doesn't
matter where it comes from whether it's
cran
or github or your company's internal
package repository
but reinvest quite a lot of work to set
up it's not a huge amount of work
but there is a simpler alternative if
you only care about crayon packages
and that's to use a crayon time machine
so there are two two alternatives here
you can use the public version of
rstudios package manager
or you can use microsoft imran but both
of these basically work the same way
they take a regular roughly daily
snapshot of cran
and so you can choose to pick a day in
the past and install
packages that were on cran on that day
now this is obviously much simpler to
set up you just have to change the repos
option
in your r profile or r configuration but
it has the limitation that it only works
for crayon packages
so to sum up you know i've told you
about some of my frustrations
that uh with home maintenance which also
i i think apply very much to code
maintenance
and particularly accepting that
the reason that you're frustrated that
the reason that these maintenance tasks
can cause frustration
is this collision between what you want
to be true
and what really is true and personally
i've found the ideas of cognitive
behavioral therapy
really useful for this helping me to
identify my automatic thoughts and come
up with more balanced rational
alternatives
that help me think about things more
productively
we also talked about the four major the
four most important stages of the tidy
verse life cycle
experimental deprecated stable and
superseded
and talked about some of the guarantees
that that
we in the tidal verse team do our best
to provide
so firstly we're to try our best to
avoid breaking changes and stable
functions
and if there are ever any breaking
changes
we're going to do this gradually through
a deprecation cycle
so you have time to discover that
there's a change in response to it
but remember if you're going to use a
function off label
uh that that voids the warranty because
we we don't know how you're using the
function it's much much much more
difficult for us to make sure it keeps
working in the same way that you're
relying on it today
finally if the hurley burley of package
updates is just too much and you want to
opt out
particularly if you have a package
that's running unattended in production
you can use tools like rn or the cran
time machines
to isolate or pick a date and time
so that your the packages you installed
do not change
ever so i hope you have enjoyed this
uh this journey of code maintenance and
home maintenance
with me and i'm really looking forward
to taking your questions in just a
couple of minutes
thank you
you